le temps la réouverture des commerçants
et 116 surtout les petits commerçants
dans les petites rues c'est à dire tout
ce qui est
les fleuristes les librairies
les autres commerces aussi d'habillement
quelle approche des fêtes de noël comme
que des gens et puis surtout pour
relancer un peu d'économies je me mets à
sa place c'est très compliqué vu ce qui
s'est passé au mois d'août et au mois de
septembre
ainsi ça recommence alors c'est pour
retourner encore dans une troisième
vague pour faire attention voilà il est
certain qu'il ya des commerces qui
pourront pas ouvrir enfin je pense
je pense que il faut ré ouvrir parce que
enfin peut-être pas nous mais il ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont en train de
mourir
c'est une autre mort que celle du virus
mais sont quand même en train de mourir
je pense que voilà c'est c'est compliqué
c'est ou où les gens qui vont être
malade des reins ou alors c'est toute la
vie qui s'écroule toute l'économie qui
s'écroule et je crois qu'on peut pas
faire durer ce habitat milliards da